hey Colonel Brian here I'm currently on
a tour across the country 18 cities with
lots of different stand-ups we're having
a blast this is not my first time though
I have toured before was 2010 and just
going down memory lane here this is the
actual map of the tour that I took the
route we took I really had conceived the
route to spell out God's will I thought
that'd be a really cool thing that
spelled out God's will across the
country of course once we've looked at
it failed to do that it just became what
looks sort of like a hawk attacking the
back of the dog and smoking a cigarette
so not quite what I was going for that
wasn't impressive we did a lot of cities
Here I am
this is spoke in Washington I did a show
and then I told everybody to meet me
outside at this piece of sculpture a
giant wagon red wagon I said everyone
meet me at the red wagon and they did
that it became is sort of a happening
which turned into an orgy and I did not
get lucky unbelievably I was the center
of an orgy that I have helped create and
not one person touched me for a brief
period of time that was a
country-western guy named slim Chester
shucks I had the beard I had this very
red beard and they just thought yeah
cowboy look
this so I had someone get me the clothes
I think my wife at the time saw a photo
of me a slim Chester Fox just was not
having it she was at home with two very
young children two babies something she
has a photo from slip Chester shucks
so she divorced slim Chester shucks
let's put that way this is me out on
stage at Bonnaroo that's amazing that's
a lot of people scantily clad none of
whom have showered in two weeks that I
remember about Bonnaroo because at the
end of my show I would go into the
audience with a guitar and I remember
going into the crowd and everybody just
hugging me it was dudes and ladies
nobody was wearing very much everybody's
stank to high heaven but the palms at
Las Vegas there was my name up in lights
in Las Vegas which I just started
thought like I don't really feel like a
Vegas guy I'm certainly not a Vegas
performer but I just thought I'm
thinking I gotta get a picture of this
this is amazing this may never happen
again
since then like a regular in Vegas with
carrot top we can actually do together
where I saw him in half then I don't put
it back together again this is the
lead-up to the tour we did rehearsals in
his giant space in the valley
it's a giant rehearsal space in the Maui
huge mammoth space and we were trying to
figure out what this show was really
when we put it together so quickly I
remember being in this giant space and
there was hardly anyone there's a couple
of my writers you know Mike Sweeney and
a couple of other writers and and Jeff
Ross sitting maybe 50 feet away from me
and I'd do something that I thought was
kind of funny and then you'd hear
nothing and you'd feel like oh my god
this idea is terrible then later on you
find out well no they were laughing like
screaming you're alone there's a writer
Matt O'Brien I regularly I was about to
say used to beat him up by realizing now
I still do Pat just attack him regularly
but I'd see him and I just start
attacking him and he it was just an
obsession of Mike's I grew up in a big
family a lot of brothers and we would
fight each other all the time kind of
from play fighting so this was a really
fun shot at me backstage I was always
backstage fighting Matt O'Brien Here I
am again wearing it I must have
admittin or something mechana debris and
whalers shirt and a backstage again
fighting Matt O'Brien I look like I sort
of look like Conor McGregor in this shot
if Conor McGregor had leukemia I was
walking around somewhere I think
Vancouver and I bought myself a Greek
fisherman's cab I found an eyepatch and
I put that on and then I got myself a
little sea captain's flight so I might
before I wore that for a while and this
is a man who needs a beating that's all
I can say is this guy this is a man who
hates it's serious medication and a
beating simultaneously it's very rare
that a doctor will prescribe both
medication and beating but that's
exactly what this guy needs oh and this
is the sparkly suit that I wore I did a
country-western number I think so I had
a sparkly suit cousin of a
country-western suit that I still have
and then I I wanted to look like Eddie
Murphy at one of his stand-up comedy
specials so I got a leather suit that
would accentuate my lack of the muscle
tone which it did perfectly oh I got fat
I forgot about the bat we thought the
show should have something really big at
the end and we had heard if we wanted a
giant inflatable animal some kind we
wanted to have kind of an Ozzy Osbourne
feel and I think we we heard that he had
like a giant inflatable dad or something
so we found the equivalent
we inflated it at the end of the show
for no reason just pure idiocy and it
was really fun it would rise up slowly
it was not very dramatic it didn't shoot
up like we thought it would it was it
would slowly slowly come to life and it
was very anticlimactic but I'm really
glad that we did that so there you have
it it was a really those great memories
some of them shocking and sad but for
the most part sweet memories of my first
big tour 2010